all right so before I hop into the chess
I have a question for the
viewers how do I pronounce the name of
this country is it qar or is it
Qatar because I've heard both
pronunciations and I'm not sure how to
introduce the the tournament that I'm
playing in but anyway this is going to
be my round two recap of the Qatar
Masters color Masters but um I just had
a super interesting game and it was a
bit shorter than yesterday but it was
action-packed
and yesterday if you saw my first round
recap I played pretty much what was a
perfect game of chess like both me and
my opponent made no
inaccuracies in this game I actually
haven't checked the engine analysis but
I have a feeling it was slightly
imperfect chess so so at the end of the
video I'll check everything stockfish
has to say but let's hop into it I was
playing Grandmaster from India uh Raja
riic rated just below 2500 and coming
into this game I knew to expect D4 but I
wasn't sure what variation my opponent
was going to play um so basically in
preparation for this game I just
reviewed my whole repertoire against the
Queen's Pawn opening and I wasn't sure
whether to expect uh Queen's gam
exchange variation with early cd5 or
maybe um the more traditional Knight C3
Knight F3 uh or what my opponent played
was the Catalan after Knight F3 Knight
F6 and G3 and I did spend a little bit
of time reviewing some lines in this
before the game but I couldn't find any
games for my opponent where he's
encountered the line I like to play so I
basically reviewed kind of the broader
rapor uh for black against the Ken so I
played what I've played in the past
which is DC4 Bishop G2 and Bishop to B4
check and after Bishop to D2 I play a
somewhat offbeat line Pawn to C5 and
when I first started playing this line
it was a nice surprise weapon cuz not
too many players are specifically
prepared for this move there's a lot of
other way more common variations against
the Catalan but I knew my opponent would
definitely be prepared for this but I
was kind of curious to see what my
opponent would prepare now to give some
context about this linee this is what I
like to call the Ray Robson variation a
good friend of mine Ray Robson he made
this line popular maybe a decade ago
maybe a bit more uh he won a bunch of
like really beautiful games in this line
from the black side and once he started
playing it I think it became a bit more
popular and another quick side note I
was debating whether to reveal this but
um I think I'll go ahead and reveal it
about 6 months to a year ago I was
having a meal with favano Carana and
somehow the topic of this variation came
up and he had casually mentioned to me
that he was preparing this line from the
black side for the last candidates
tournament and I had asked him if it's
okay for me to reveal that uh at some
point in in a video so I guess is this
is me revealing that but I was trying to
pick his brain about this line and try
and get a sense of like what the most
testing options were uh for white um but
I I didn't really remember much of our
conversation from however many months
ago but uh the thought came to mind
during the game that oh yeah favano was
prepping this for the candidates I don't
think he ever had any games in this line
as far as I know at least recently
anyway it's a cool variation white does
have a lot of options here uh my
opponent opted for Bishop takes B4 which
is one of the most common moves and I
take back and then Knight to
E5 and yeah this is all pretty standard
prep and in this position the main line
is Knight takes C4 after which there's a
cool variation Knight C6 E3 and then
E5 and I think for several years this
used to be the main line and there's a
lot of different options here for white
between taking the pawn and E5 there's
also line D5 B5 which gets very crazy
but my opponent played a different move
rather than taking on C4 he played Pawn
A3 and I'm pretty sure this move has
become a bit more trendy recently we
check in the Masters database there are
good handful of games uh from this
position among a lot of uh lot of strong
Grand
Masters and I want to note that uh
before the game today this morning I had
reviewed the game between Ari and
prananda but I only reviewed it like
very briefly and during the game I was
like trying to recall what the initial
move order was um now I was able to
recall the next few moves for black so I
was basically copying progan On's play I
start with Knight D5 which is maybe a
weird move to play moving the same piece
twice without developing the queen side
pieces uh but the idea is to reinforce
B4 and also block the diagonal there's
cases where I want to play B5 for
example if white takes on B4 I think I'd
be happy to play B5 right away and and
get some stable pawns and prepare Bishop
B7 but my opponent played Knight takes
C4 which is the main line and I play
Knight C6 he castles and then I play A5
and when I play 85 I was pretty sure we
were still following this aragi pragnan
game but I didn't really remember
anything after that and up until this
point my opponent was just blitzing out
the moves we can see he has three
minutes more than he started with
because there is a 30 second
increment but after I played
A5 uh my opponent took a very very long
think so I was happy to at least have
survived my opponent's preparation and
it was clear that after this move my
opponent was most likely out of his
pregame prep and we were both in
relatively fresh
territory now I want to share a quick
story during during my opponent's very
long think I was sitting at the board
for uh for a good portion of it and at
some point none other than Magnus
Carlson starts walking towards our board
and uh he took a very quick look at the
position but it was no more than like a
split second of him glancing at our
position and he just walked away I was
curious if he like recognized the
opening from the Prague Ari game or
maybe he just wanted to um yeah see see
what was going on uh keep track of how
I'm doing but uh in that moment I felt a
little bit special that the world
champion or not the world champion but
the um yeah the the number one player in
the world was observing my game so
anyway uh after my opponent's long think
he played Queen D2 We can see that yeah
my opponent spent about 36 minutes on
this move and yeah it took me a little
bit to understand the reason for this
move because it does block the
development of the B1 Knight but there
are some benefits white is preparing
Rook C1 to get the Rook to the only open
file on the board and White's also
applying a bit of pressure to B4 and A5
and there's cases where if um like my B
Pawn goes away then A5 could be attacked
up to three times by the queen Knight
and Rook so yeah I think Queen D2 it was
really a move to improve a little bit
and put the ball back in my
courts and I took my first long think of
the game here and I decided to play Pawn
to B6 which I knew was a pretty standard
idea and I had some vague memory of prag
nand playing this against ERI um
although it wasn't the exact position
and the point of this move even though
it looks a little bit weakening because
now my knight on C6 is undefended
there's potential pins along long
diagonal um I do want to just develop my
light squ Bishop either to B7 or to A6
and I didn't really want to play B5
because then Bishop A6 is no longer a
possibility but in hindsight maybe I
should have spent more time considering
B5 to get the initiative cuz we're going
to see here that my opponent just
immediately seizes control over the game
and basically for the next few moves is
making threat after threat uh starting
with Pawn E4 hitting my knight and I had
seen this possibility when I played B6
but I didn't think it was too
Troublesome but then the more I thought
the more I realized that yeah things are
like almost crumbling for black
immediately
CU after I mve the Knight I played
Knight E7 I should note that if I play
Knight
F6 then there's E5 hitting the Knight
again and white can plan a knight on D6
and this didn't look so
pleasant so I played Knight E7 to make
sure that E5 doesn't come with Tempo and
I am hitting the pawn on D4 but my
opponent now strikes with Pawn
D5 and now it's a question what to do
with my knight and at first glance it it
does look like black is losing material
because if I take take and move the
Knight then maybe I'm not losing
material but it looks very ugly with D6
in the air and this diagonal being a
huge weapon for uh this white
Bishop but um yeah I I had a move in
mind here after my opponent played D5 I
played the counterattacking move not
moving this Knight but playing Bishop to
A6 attacking the undefended Knight on
C4 and I had seen this possibility from
when I played B6 and I thought that it
leads to like an interesting position
but I had a very hard time calculating
Beyond this just because there's a lot
of different branches and things can get
very messy from here and uh yeah things
definitely got very messy as we're about
to see so my opponent played Rook C1
defending the Knight I took on
C4 and here I was expecting my opponent
to take back I was calculating lines
like Knight E5 and Rook D4 and then take
and then take and then Knight F5
eventually and I thought black is doing
okay with the two knights and white
being a little bit behind development on
the queen side uh but we didn't go into
this because instead of taking the
bishop my opponent took the Knight which
surprised me a bit because I thought if
my opponent wants to go for that line he
could have taken
here uh and this would have been I guess
a transposition like we could have
reached the same position from a couple
different move orders but yeah he chose
this move order Rook C1 take and take
and now it's just a really weird
situation where white has this Pawn on
C6 but I can't take it because my
Bishop's attacked and I don't want to
trade Queens because that helps white
complete development and meanwhile
there's still this lingering Pawn
tension on the queen side and if I move
my Bishop then The Rook is supporting
this like dangerous pass Pawn not to
mention the bishop has potential if
white ever gets an E5 then um yeah this
Pawn can be a very annoying thing to
deal with so the move I ended up playing
here was Pawn to
B5 and what this does is it tries to
cement the Bishop on C4 and make it so
The Rook is cut off in defending the
pawn and I thought for sure that this
Pawn should be way more of a weakness
than it is a strength uh but we're going
to see that my opponent was super
resourceful and found ways to actually
turn this Pawn into a serious weapon in
just a few moves uh so going forward
from here my opponent traded Queens and
here it seems like the obvious recapture
is Rook F takes d8 but I took some time
here trying to make sense of the
differences between Rook F and Rook a
takes d8 and I ended up going for Rook a
takes d8 mainly because I didn't want to
allow the trade on the a file if I take
with FR Rook then white can take take
and I lose time having to take back and
then white gets some initiative against
my Bishop so I thought that if I take
with a rook which is what I played then
the differences after takes takes we're
not trading Rooks and it's hard for
white to develop here because the Knight
can't come to D2 and my my setup is
actually very nice in restricting the
Knight on B1 so we got to this position
and instead of taking on B4 my opponent
played the move
C7 and I saw this was a possibility from
a distance but I really didn't think it
was that threatening because and the
pawn has no Defenders I play the move
Rook D7 looks like the pawn is just a
goner uh but the problem becomes it's
hard for me to actually win the pawn
because there's so many cases where if I
take there's Pawn
B3 exploiting the pinned Bishop
Meanwhile my Bishop doesn't have too
many squares and here my opponent played
a move which I had
overlooked very strong move I think Pawn
to A4 and it feels like a weird move
because it just seems like at some point
white should take and try and open the a
file but A4 is a very nice way of trying
to destabilize my pawn bishop
combination and White's creating a
situation where I can't take the pawn on
C7 if I take it uh first of all there's
B3 but yeah second L there's takes and
yeah B3 is still coming so yeah I was in
a bit of a predicament here and I played
the only move which I thought keeps me
alive which is Knight to C6 the idea
being after takes I take on
B5 and it seems like I'm barely holding
things together because my Bishop
defends a knight which defends upon Pawn
the Knight blocks a C file so I I am
likely threatening to win the pawn on C7
but then when we got to this position I
realized that white has a
really like amazing tactical idea which
I just completely overlooked uh there's
a move here Rook takes
A5 and I couldn't prevent it because we
already got to the position but as I
started to calculate this move I
realized there's just some crazy crazy
variations uh now my opponent didn't
play this move I'm pretty sure the
reason why he didn't play it is because
after Knight takes A5 of course IDE is
to queen there's a beautiful resource
for black Rook D1 check point being if
Rook takes D1 then it's all just a fair
trade it's equal material again and if
anything black should be better here
with some more activity on the queen
side um but there's a really cool line
Bishop F1 and I am down a queen here I
can't take the queen because I get back
rank mated but I can take on
F1 and The Rook can't take back because
I win the queen but white has King G2
and I was trying to
calculate this position from a distance
and trying to evaluate like what's going
on and it seems like like maybe White's
better having the material advantage uh
but then I realized there's a beautiful
move for Black Knight C6 I'm not sure if
this is objectively like the best
approach but once I saw Knight C6 I
pretty much concluded that black
shouldn't be worse here because I'm
obstructing the relationship between the
queen and the rook and I'm essentially
winning back enough material because I'm
threatening to take the queen if white
wants to Save the Queen then I take the
rook and then we can get a position like
this where yeah only black is playing
for a win I assume this um yeah this
should be very close to winning for
black so I thought this was a really
cool line uh this Knight C6 move where
there's just some crazy geometry with
the the queen and both Rooks like The
Rook on F1 and The Rook on uh f8 staring
at White's pieces and the night
disconnecting them I thought was just
really really beautiful but the beauty
did not play out at least in this
variation but the beauty played out in a
different VAR ation cuz after Bishop
takes B5 my opponent played Bishop to F1
and this move I didn't quite see coming
although I should have because it's
definitely a main cidate move for white
attacking my Bishop trying to remove the
guard of the NY C6 and what ends up
happening I think I'm still taking time
to process basically for the the rest of
the game like both sides are are are
walking a tight rope so let me show what
happened I took the bishop on
F1 and I was expecting King takes F1 but
my opponent played Rook takes C6 and
when he played this move I thought isn't
this just losing because I have Rook D1
and I calculated this when my opponent
played Bishop F1 I pretty quickly play
Rook D1 but I realized very quickly that
I'm not winning here because white
has uh a really nice resource I should
explain I'm threatening check miden one
with Bishop H3 uh and if F4 making LOF
for the king I have Bishop B5 to win The
Rook so at first glance it does look
promising for black but white has a move
Knight
D2 and my discovered checks moving the
bishop don't work because my rook's
attacked like Bishop H3 is not Checkmate
because Rook takes D1 I'm just
losing so he played Knight D2 and of
course White's Rook is hanging and I
take
it but after he takes my Bishop again
white can't queen because uh Bishop H3
is mating so he takes the bishop and now
white is the one with the massive threat
of promoting the pawn and at this
point I thought I was losing because
after I play Rook C8 which I played my
opponent plays Rook
D6
and as this line was approaching and
once we got to this position I was
pretty much set on playing the move King
f8 and going into a line after Rook d8
King E7 take King
D7 where I'm pretty sure white should be
objectively winning here although Maybe
there's some uh some chances for black
to hold after this this this like this
was my main calculation and I thought
okay maybe I have chances to get some
counterplay with my um my two-on-one
majority on the queen
side but once we got
to this position after Rook
D6 I
realized I don't have to play King f8
there's a different way to deal with a
threat of Rook d8
and I really should have seen the move
here from several moves ago but I only
realized it once we got to this position
I'm very thankful I didn't just Blitz
out king f8 because I was very close to
just playing this quickly at first I
assumed it was my only move but I think
this is a really nice exercise for
viewers uh if you want to pause the
video and find the best move for black
feel free to do so and I think the
reason why it just took me a long time
to find the move was it just feels very
unnatural but the move is to return to
f8 even though I had just put my Rook on
C8 from f8 uh the reason why it makes
sense to return is after Rook d8 my
rook's defended and I'm in time to play
Rook C1 and White's not queening and
because White's not queening white can't
win this position so once we got to this
position after Rook f8 my opponent took
a small think and
realized what's happening in the
situation and white has nothing better
than to repeat the position Rook C6 and
I have nothing better than to also
repeat Rook C8 and the game pretty
abruptly ends in three-fold repetition
ending just before move
30 um there is a 30 move no draw rule
for the tournament like you're not
allowed to offer a draw before move 30
so I actually had to claim the
three-fold and call over an Arbiter but
we did um we did draw after 29 moves
yeah I I still don't know like if if
anything was missed in these crazy
complications but I think now is the
time to check with stockfish so I have
the the game open in another chapter and
I already ran the engine analysis but I
haven't looked at it yet so let's click
enable and let's
see was this another perfect
game oh
wow
wow we both made one
blunder I made it one inaccuracy too
okay so we see the graph I was I was
losing at some point KN C6 was a
blunder okay so let's go back with the
engine and
see let's see what stockfish has to
say uh okay so the opening was all
standard like this was all prep from
both of
us and
then after Queen
D2 ah so B6 was
inaccurate yeah the engine says
B5 b593 wow that E3 looks awkward yeah
maybe white has some slight Edge in this
position might have to do some deeper
opening prep in this
line so B6 was inaccurate and yeah
actually white does have a significant
edge here D5 let's keep going so
apparently this is all fine
White's still a bit better maybe E5 is
slightly
preferable but let's get to the
blunder so Knight C6 was a
blunder ah my opponent actually told me
this after the game that he um he should
have played Bishop F1 before taking I
think he's very right that yeah this
line didn't work because of what
happened in the game
and once Bishop F1 was
played then yeah then we just played
into this drawing line Rook f8 was the
only move to secure the
draw so going back let me try and
explain the
reason why white should play Bishop F1
first is
now after
takes what's the
difference ah white can just take back
with with the King okay Rook C6
apparently is also winning but just King
takes his simpler and my Knight's
attacked and I can't take the pawn
because there's still this tension take
here and it's it's just
winning is it really that
simple and if I take on
C7 then a takes B5 my my whole position
is
crumbling
wow so I'm very fortunate
to escape with a draw in this game like
black has no defense after Bishop
F1 my opponent just played it in the
wrong order basically allowed me this
resource with takes and then and then
Rook D1 of course I should note here
that after King takes like this is
totally fine because there's no a takes
B5 like the pawns have already been
traded
so uh I guess I'm I'm very fortunate in
this game to have survived not quite a
perfect game this is this is imperfect
chest but definitely some lessons to
take
away so yeah two draws to start the
tourment I am one out of
two and I'm sure a lot of people
watching this know by now but maybe some
people don't know that um Magnus Carlson
lost his game today
so he's also at one out of two so there
is a
possibility I'll play Magnus Carlson but
I think it's still pretty slim because
we were
both black in round two but who knows
like uh if I play Magnus tomorrow it'll
be uh it'll be a fun
experience if I don't it'll still be a
fun experience cuz I I'll definitely
play a stronger opponent
tomorrow so uh I think that wraps it up
thanks everyone for watching stay tuned
for more chess be sure to check out the
twitch Channel everyday Jonathan trance
is doing commentary twitch.tv/ amrosen
and also stay tuned for more Recaps and
I'll see you guys soon